hello i am chanakar and i will be
discussing on surveillance of sars covet
2
variants of concern from waste water
samples based on
ngs data
i am a masters student pursuing
biotechnology at amity university noida
the surge in the new severe acute
respiratory syndrome coronavirus 2
variants of concern posed major threat
cause of change in genome
it has the ability of host response
the mutations in gene encodes for spike
protein accounts for most of the
influential variants of concern
so the objective of this project is to
learn and analyze variance of concern
and sample and perform
msa and phylogenetic analysis using ngs
data employing tbioinfo server
coronavirus a contagious disease that is
caused by virus was first known case
identified in wuhan china
majorly transmitted by contaminated air
by the droplets of virus sars covid ii
variants are grouped in clades or
lineage and who established nomenclature
for tracking sars covid ii genetic
lineage by giscid
pango and next strain
labeling of variants were done with
greek alphabets like alpha beta gamma
this virus affects upper and lower
respiratory tract
so it is the causative agent of covet 19
and infected
millions of people and caused death
worldwide
genome of sars kovit2 is made up of two
proteins structural and non-structural
protein
structural protein made up of four genes
envelope membrane spike and nucleocapsid
whereas
non-structural proteins are mostly
enzymes playing vital role in viral
replication
virus
ss host cells via angiotensin converting
enzyme to
found on the surface of alveolar cells
and the virus uses a special surface
glycoprotein called a spike to connect
to the ace2 receptor and enters the host
cells
data overview the dataset was made
available on ncbi and downloaded from
sre run table
sample analysis was performed on sewage
across six major cities of uk and it
shows genetic diversity genetic variants
in wastewater reflect similar snps
then complete genome of sars covid ii as
reference genome downloaded from ncbi in
genbank
to study translation of nucleotide to
amino acids
exploration
bioinformatics used for analysis of
biological information
large volume of biological data is
generated which changed way of
biomedical research
uncovering biological phenomena by
mining big data can lead to discoveries
of drug discovery and drug response
various pipelines were performed for
working on the project like variant
calling phylogenetic analysis
mutability differential mutation copy
number variation
variant calling variant calling refers
to the task of identifying possible
variations in genome or transcriptome
sequence with respect to chosen
reference sequence it is of two types
germline variant calling and somatic
variant calling
germline variant calling
this reference sequence is the standard
for species of interest whereas somatic
variant calling this reference is the
genome of chosen control somatic cell
samples
talking about phylogenetic analysis
phylogenetic analysis pipeline performed
to understand the relationship and
origin it is used to analyze genetic and
molecular difference between
dna sequence to determine the
evolutionary relationship
mutability and copy number variation
pipelines performed as mutability
describes the observed rate of a given
position to the change whereas copy
number variation is phenomena in which
sections of genome are repeated and
number of repeats in genome varies
between individual
surveillance of sars over 2 variants of
concern from wastewater sample based on
ngs data methodology involves
first finding the data set available on
ncbi
second running msa and phylogenetic
pipeline using t bioinfo server which
involves selecting pipeline and
parameters like
for ngs data faster queue format is
taken and data set is uploaded with
reference genome
pipeline is created
once the pipeline is started
boutique 2 is selected for aligning
reads on reference genome
consensus module and per nucleotide
module selected to generate pro
nucleotide position
then msa performed at nucleotide level
and then at amino acid level
after that phylogenetic tree is
generated using beast mode and then end
button is clicked to complete the
pipeline
next step is to find lineage of samples
from sars pangolin server for which
pangolin
cov lineage dot org
used
it allows users to provide most likely
to a source covet to genome sequence
web applications selected and faster
files are uploaded to get closest
lineage for each sequence
mutation and amino acids are found in
samples by outbreak dot info dot
where lineage mutation tracker selected
and then select on own lineage used
next click on choose variant type and
mutation and enter lineage of sample to
find the mutation
next using unipro eugene msa pipeline
opened which highlights nucleotide and
the mutations
phylogenetic tree was obtained where
samples err 5019764
and err5019769
lying in same plate have closer
evolutionary relationship with reference
genome
whereas err5019762
share distinct evolutionary relationship
with outgroup samples
samples shows evolvement from common
lineage with b point one point one
here after analyzing the samples three
variant types were found
b
b point one b point one point one
showing the mutation in amino acid
sequence of different lineage
this explains mutation in nucleotide
sequence in msa table
mutation found at 241 position in c and
t bases with 25 and 75 percent
respectively
at position
3037 mutation in c and t bases where t
is 66.7 percent and c is 33.3 percent
position 9634 results showing mutation
in nucleotide sequence in adenine and
thymine bases with coverage of 41.6 and
58.4 percent
cytosine and thymine based mutation at
position 14408
observed where t is 66.7 percent and c
is 33.7 percent
genome sequencing of sars covet 2 from
wastewater is valuable tool monitoring
lineages
uk seaweed samples analyzed and msa and
phylogenetic analysis
done using t bioinfo server
sample err5019770
and err5019768
lies in same plate and share close
evolutionary relationship
err 501 9764
and err5019769
two lie in same plate share close
evolutionary relation with reference
genome since common node
mutations can be seen in genes besides
spike protein variants analyzed in
samples and three variants were found
hence different variants of concern were
detected in wastewater samples closest
lineage for each samples were detected
which indicated that they are variants
of alpha and mutation of these genes
were discovered
msa table helped to find mutation and
phylogenetic tree indicated the
evolution with reference sequence of
sample the data helped to identify
common mutation that occurred with time
so these are the references of my work
hope it helps thank you